a South Florida nursing home is now
facing a criminal investigation after
eight patients died in sweltering
conditions the deaths happened after the
facility lost air conditioning during
Hurricane Emma
rescue crews had to evacuate the home it
is now closed more than a hundred and
fifty elderly patients were stranded in
near 90-degree heat the discovery led
state and local officials to order
inspections of other nursing facilities
that nursing home in Hollywood Florida
told County officials the day before
that there was no electricity but the
facility did not evacuate the patients
there
Jonathan Vigliotti is outside the
Rehabilitation Center with the latest
Jonathan good morning good morning
gallon the scale of this tragedy is
highlighted by just how close this
nursing home was to help take a look at
this it is across the street from a
hospital literally 15 steps from a
building that had working power and air
conditioning now this morning as you can
imagine so many people asking why more
wasn't done to prevent this tragedy from
happening I open my mouth my niece I
said oh my god I'll be nice one with him
Carmen Rodriguez is family to the oldest
victim in this tragedy 19 9 year old
Albertina Vega
they have no air condition in there how
they had those four people having
problems breathing this is very tragic
Hollywood Police Chief Tom Sanchez says
investigators believe the deaths were
heat related they were utilizing
portable AC units which were
insignificant to reduce the excessive
heat in the facility at 3 a.m. Wednesday
fire rescue crews responded to a 911
nursing home reporting a cardiac arrest
an hour later another 911 call this time
a patient was having trouble breathing a
fire official then reported concerns
about the facility when rescuers
responded to a third call they found
three dead bodies on the second floor
that was described as extremely hot an
evacuation order began around 6:15 a.m.
in coordination with staff from Memorial
Hospital across the street it took three
hours to evacuate all 158 patient
many filed out on stretchers and in
wheelchairs they were taken to various
local hospitals and treated for
respiratory distress dehydration and
heat related issues family members
frantically searched for loved ones the
nursing home has a poor record with
regulators and is ranked as much below
average with a 1 out of 5 rating on a
federal nursing home ranking website and
a statement the facility says they
immediately contacted Florida Power &
Light after the air-conditioning broke
down and also reached out to local and
emergency first responders Florida
Senator Bill Nelson has asked for a
federal investigation into the incident
I think it is an emerging scandal of
gargantuan proportions and police went
door to door yesterday inspecting all of
the city's 42 nursing homes we're told
one was also found without power and
those inside had to be evacuated and now
some members of family that were inside
this nursing home say they're frustrated
they didn't actually hear from the staff
at all some of the first calls they got
were from media and reporters looking
for interviews Charlie thank you so much
Jonathan